okay welcome back so in the last video
we talked about how to scale up Mohr's
balance truncation algorithm two really
really big dynamical systems using the
balanced proper orthogonal decomposition
of wilcoxon rally 2002-2005 papers we
talked about how you can get rank or
approximations of these graeme ins or
you could bypass grampians altogether
and just work on these impulse response
snapshot matrices curly C and curly o
here so you build this big Hankel matrix
you SVD it you use some math and you get
a model but the central problem here is
what if usually the number of actuators
the dimension of U is small in my
airfoil example maybe I can do a couple
of things to pitch you know the airfoil
i've got one or two control knobs but in
a lot of systems my measurements might
be exceedingly high dimensional I might
actually have the luxury in my
simulation of measuring the full state X
I can measure a million things in my
simulation but I can't do an impulse
response so these impulse responses
require you to give a delta function in
every independent channel of U or Y and
so if Y is a million measurements I
can't realistically give an impulse to
each of those million inputs separately
and collect all that data that would
take forever in a computer fill all of
your hard drives and you'd never be able
to work with these objects so this was
an innovation that rrally made in 2005
was essentially to realize most
dynamical systems even very high
dimensional ones like million
dimensional systems if you kick them and
you measure the output response there's
some dominant patterns and coherent
structures that emerge from that data in
this this controllability matrix C so
essentially what I can do is I could
take this controllability matrix C and I
could take its singular value
decomposition I'm gonna just abuse
notation and call it u u Sigma this is a
different Sigma maybe I'll call it a
diagonal matrix D just so I don't
confuse everyone
you diagonal matrix D V transpose and
what we find is that the
patterns that are excited by impulse
responses in the inputs are given by the
first columns of U so I can basically
describe my million dimensional system
in terms of a small handful of modes or
you know shapes that I can add up in a
linear combination to reconstruct X so
basically this says X is pretty well
approximated by u alpha where I keep the
first let's say five columns of U and
then this is a five dimensional vector
telling me the mixture of those modes
these are called my proper orthogonal
decomposition modes p OD people do this
all the time in fluids and physics and
optics that compute P OD of their
measurement data to find what are the
coherent structures in this high
dimensional data and what what Rallye
did was he realized that this adjoint
matrix I could essentially instead of
impulsively exciting every element of my
state independently might if I'm
measuring the full state I can do these
coordinated impulses where I impulsively
excite these alpha modes instead I can
excite p OD mode one and see how that
rings through the dynamics I can excite
p OD mode two and see how that rings
through the dynamics and that
approximates what would happen if you
went through this full impulse response
on every element of Y and so in that
case the adjoint equation becomes XK
plus 1 equals a star XK but now instead
of C star Y we have C star u u I'm gonna
call this alpha okay and so basically
you know if I was measuring this is for
if I measured if we measure y equals x
we measure the full state then instead
of this being an X here I can replace it
with u alpha and then this is a matrix
and I only have to do order R impulse
experiments remember I shouldn't say
experiment these are numerical
experiments they're simulations but
remember for every single measurement in
alpha
I have to do a full simulation I mean an
impulse response simulation literally
means I run my code for that Delta
function and I measure what happens this
could take days or weeks to collect one
of these and so I want to make this as
small as possible and so what what
klancy rally did was he said okay find
the dominant patterns in the data and
only excite those dominant patterns for
the adjoint response so that's another
critical innovation when you're going to
very high dimensional systems and if you
have full state measurements if you want
a model based on full state measurements
you do p OD on your direct snapshots you
get your p OD modes these are the
dominant coherent structures and then
you in the adjoint equation you only
excite those modes instead of directly
exciting every channel of X pretty cool
idea okay so next we're going to code
this up and see what happens
thank you